in the red beret Captain Ibrahim troire
Burkina faso's new Junta leader and
self-appointed president thousands
gathered in the capital in what seemed
like a Victory Parade after Friday's
coup for the outside
grabbing power in the capital wagadugu
proved easier than fighting armed groups
in the north of the country where
soldiers face setbacks at the hands of
armed groups linked to isil in al-Qaeda
the state has lost control of almost
half of the country so now there is a
new Junta and a new leader but the old
challenges remain we are in the streets
not because we support encourage it but
to find unity and Truth we are here to
support our military to find peace
because we have suffered so much at the
hands of terrorists
away from the capital is an unfolding
humanitarian crisis almost 2 million
people are displaced fleeing clashes and
violence most are children malnutrition
is common armed groups prevent Aid
agencies from delivering help
I hosted Junta liba who took over in a
coup last January promised to resolve
the humanitarian and security situation
but despite the military support of
France the former colonial power
burkina's forces have been overrun
supporters of the coup burnt tires in
front of the French Embassy and looted
french-owned businesses they blamed
France for their losses
this demonstrator says he hopes the
Nugent power will follow the example of
neighboring Mali where the Russian
security company Wagner has been brought
in to fight armed groups long live
cricket
Long Live Russia
[Applause]
on a pickup truck a soldier involved in
the coup waves a Russian flag
this is a blow to France and the West
who are losing their influence in the
Sahel a desire for change born of
disarray and Desperation
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera Dakar